All right.
Okay. What's up? What's your background?
>> Uh, can you hear me, sir?
>> Yes, I can hear you. Okay. Joe Ro, take
it easy. I'll be with you next. So,
what's your background?
>> As of like uh what? What do you What do
you mean? I'm a Christian.
>> What kind of Christian?
>> Uh, I don't know. Like I don't have like
a denomination like I believe in father,
son, holy spirit.
>> What do you believe about them? They're
trinity.
>> Yes, sir.
>> Okay. So, what's your question? Let me
help you.
>> I just have a question for my friends.
My friends asked me uh
>> just I think it's a stupid question, but
I don't know how to answer it.
>> Give them a stupid answer. So, what's
>> I feel like you I feel like you've
answered it before, but I couldn't
>> What is it?
>> There's just so many videos I just
couldn't seem to find it. But
>> yeah, what's the question?
>> They say uh God has like a everything is
possible through God, right? With God.
>> I don't know what they mean. Everything
is possible through God. Like anything
is possible. Like he's able to do
anything. Right.
>> I don't know what they mean by anything.
>> Like he's capable of doing anything.
Like
>> I don't know what they mean by anything.
This is the fourth time I repeated it.
>> All right. So they say if God is so
powerful and he's he can do everything.
Can he and he's so strong?
>> Everything. What do you mean by
everything?
>> Like he's the creator. He created earth.
He he can create mountains. He can move
them. Right.
>> Okay. So if you know he created the
universe that means it's within his
ability to then ease or erase the
creation he brought into being right.
>> Yes sir.
>> Okay.
>> But the but their question is he can do
all that and they say can he make a
mountain so heavy that he can't move it
or can he just like a dumb
>> one of the things that's within
God's abilities. Where'd you get your
definition of what God can do?
I feel like I've just read that he's
cap. He's everything. There's no He's
like bound. There's no limit. He's
>> Well, are you answering that what you
feel? Because that shows you're
biblically illiterate because the Bible
says there's a lot of things that God
cannot do. So, can God cease to exist?
>> No.
>> No. But you said he can do anything. Why
can't he cease to exist?
>> I know. Like he can't lie. He can't
cease to exist.
>> You just answered your question. So,
what does it mean that God can do
everything and anything?
I guess I I just need to
I need to read more, learn more.
>> That's my answer to you. When I was
asking the question, I was answering
your friends. So, what do you mean he
can do anything?
>> You're asking me if what what do I mean
when he can do anything?
>> You understand? When I asked you the
question, I was answering the objection
of your friends.
>> I got you. I got you.
>> So, when your friends tell me, "Can God
do anything?" What do you mean by
anything?
>> And then they and then they ask the
question.
And what question
>> can he build? Can he make a mountain so
heavy?
>> That's part of the things that God can
can do. Where'd you get your definition
of what anything and everything means?
>> So, is there an answer besides that?
Besides asking them the question,
>> I just answered your question. You still
didn't get it.
>> I'm g have to rewatch this because I
feel stupid. I'm a little nervous and
I'm just
>> Who told you?
>> Nobody told me. Nobody told me. Nobody
told me.
Who told you
that God can do anything even do that
which is logically inconsistent?
If God is
reality and truth and wisdom and reason,
then to ask God to do something that's
logically inconsistent means that God
has to go against his nature. To say
that he can build a mountain so big that
he cannot lift is illogical because by
the very definition of God, he is the
one who not only creates but has to
sustain the thing that he creates. So
how can he create something that is
beyond his ability to sustain which is
logically impossible?
He can't. I mean
that's the answer. So tell your friends,
stop with these stupid childish games
because they don't know what it means
for God to be God and what it means for
God to be able to do anything and
everything. Because to say that God
creates, the moment you say he creates,
he has to then be able to sustain it. So
how can he create something that he
cannot sustain?
>> Yeah. Because he can sustain everything.
Everything in earth is controlled by him
and he's in control of every single
>> answer. How can God create something he
cannot sustain? Because if you're
telling me can he create a mountain so
big he cannot lift that means he's
creating something that he cannot
sustain then how can he create it if he
cannot sustain it and preserve it.
>> Yes sir.
>> You see why I'm already answering you by
asking the question show your friends
how stupid they are not you how stupid
they are.
>> Yes sir.
>> You understand is that's what I'm
saying. So just like God cannot cease to
exist because God by his very nature is
life. How can he then cease to live if
he is life?
And how can God create something beyond
his capacity to sustain?
I mean that's like asking me
can 2 plus two be five.
>> Nope.
>> But why not? God can do anything.
>> Yeah, but he can't. I mean that's just
that's
>> because mathematics is a reflection of
the mind of God. Because mathematics do
not exist independently from the mind of
God. So that tells you that God's mind
is logically consistent. It may be on
our ability to comprehend but it's not
irrational or illogical because logic
itself flows from God. God is a source
of logic. There would be no logic if
there wasn't God. Logic is a reflection
of God's mind. Mathematics would be a
reflection of God's mind. Right?
>> Yes sir.
>> So to tell me that God can create a
mountain he cannot lift. Well, number
one, how can he create something that he
cannot sustain?
>> I don't know what they're going to say.
>> No, they're they're going to realize
they're stupider than Muhammad.
You
>> get my point?
>> Yes, sir.
>> So, that's why now next time then you
knock their teeth out because I see you
box. Knock their teeth out. After you
give the answer, do like a three- punch
combination. Lights out.
>> Hey, man. Can I just want to say thank
you for going live every day. I mean,
I've watched so much and learned so
much. I mean, God bless you, man. Thank
you.
>> Love you, brother. So, you know how to
answer it now, right?
>> Yes, sir. Thank you. I appreciate you.
>> Thank you for asking a legit question
and not send me on rabbit trails about,
"Hey, I got angry at you. You know, I'm
angry at my dad. How can I stop getting
angry because I want to stay married,
not live in my mommy's basement?"
>> Yes, sir.
>> Okay, Wimberly, knock them out for me
after you answer that. And how do you
feel? Huh? Bam. Right there. I scared.
>> And uh I see you're with your daughters.
I hope you have a enjoy your night with
your family and God bless you.
>> Love you.
>> Make sure you win the Wimble. Was it
Wimberly Cup for me?
>> Wimberly Cook.
>> Wimbledon. That's Wimbledon. I'm sorry.
That's I don't know my sports. I only
know my buffets.
>> Yes, sir.
>> God bless you, brother.
>> God bless.
>> Bye-bye.
The cat. I scared the hell out of Cat
Sarah. Ketchup. You see, that's what I
was trying to say. What do you mean he
can do anything? Can he cease to exist?
It's like saying that Protestant
believer can cease to be ugly, right?
Within human possibility, that's
impossible. Now, God can do it, but I'm
talking about it's like saying, "Hey,
can Protestant believer stop being
humanly ugly?" You know, is it within
the realm of human potentiality and the
ability of humanity to make someone this
hideously ugly look beautiful like David
Wood, Protestant believer and posit? No.
That's humanly impossible. So, even with
God, there are things that God cannot
do. All
right.